chicago looks like a war zone with
shootings and homicides on the rise
over 1600 people have been shot and over
250 people have been murdered so far
this year alone
so what's mayor lori lightfoot doing
about it well she's apparently too busy
sending
insane emails to staffers complaining
about her schedule
like in january when she wrote quote i
need office time
every day 16 times in a row
and then followed up writing quote not
just once
a week or some days every day
10 times greg
i got a side with lori yeah i think she
needs office time but it's weird to
write it like 16 times in a row
you know uh if any of us had done this
hr would call we would get a leave of
absence to get proper treatment because
it's insane i mean this is a sign of
insane repetitive weirdness and also a
lack of priorities like when you're
talking about
like she doesn't feel she doesn't send
emails like that about the murder rate
and then she claims she claimed uh that
since this happened the problem had been
solved and the problem would solve
because everybody quit
oh all the people that she was
complaining about are gone um
i it is crazy should i should we play
emily compagno
reading in this out loud uh i didn't
know we had it but if you'd like to
read we have her doing an oral uh
presentation of the actual email okay
since my prior requests for office time
are routinely ignored
i am now resorting to this i need office
time
every day i need office time every day i
need office i'm ready i need office time
need office time every day i need office
time every day i need office time every
day i need all this time every day i
made off this time every day i need
office time every day i need all this
time every day i need office time every
day i need office time every day i need
office time every day i need all the
time every day
so that's crazy that's insane yes
and she's mayor how how did she get
elected
that's what drives me crazy she ticked
all the right boxes
but they overlooked that she may not be
well
what do you think dana do you think this
is a sign of insanity or do you think
maybe her staff doesn't listen
so she has to say it over and over and
over again i think she needs office time
every day
yeah she does and everybody needs a
little office time every day then like
the time
calendar to think i don't know oh like
off this time
yeah yeah what do you mean you know like
in little office time
private time yes oh my gosh i hadn't
thought of that
i guess it's possible i think that she
is also under a tremendous amount of
pressure right because this is a problem
that's been
building for decades and they do not
accurately diagnose the problem
that there seems to be like an inability
to or an unwillingness to to try to
really solve it and so
maybe that was just a way for her to
express some frustration
i think it would be better to not put it
in an email but just to yell
yell 16 times
um listen if she's in her office in
office time
solving the murder rise maybe that could
solve it but she's not
she's now saying that's not my
responsibility harold she says
it's the federal government's
responsibility listen
cities individually cannot tackle this
problem on its own
we just cannot in chicago we've done
absolutely everything possible and
we need help from the federal government
because this is a
national problem so that's a lie because
trump tried to help chicago
dozens of times finally they sent in
gang task force
and even then lori was like no no no
stay out of chicago
well she clearly changed uh she's
changed her mind and she may say it a
few times
[Laughter]
yes and seriously i think the gun
problem in chicago as it is everywhere
you have to wonder how do these kids how
do these gang members how do these
people who are using these guns how do
they find them how do they buy them
they don't walk into a gun store and
flash id and get a gun they don't go to
a gun
a gun show and are able to get it every
car has a serial
number on it so we you see these great
commercials about carfax you can tell
what kind of accent the cars had you
know the owners of the cars you don't go
probing into their background but you
know these things but the gun
it seems weird that thousands of guns
find their way into urban areas
to kids who can't get a good book can't
find a healthy food option can't find
health care can't find
a good job but they can find the most
incredible guns
and engage in the most awful deadly
fatal things now
i'm not this is not to to give any mayor
pass every mayor and every certainly
mayor lightfoot like all of us are open
for criticism but at some point
we have to wonder our not people talk
about our gun laws this is just
understanding who owned the gun before
who bought it and allowed it to get
out to all of these kids kids who would
not be able to buy
otherwise are criminals who certainly
wouldn't qualify to buy a gun
otherwise well they're getting them from
gangs and cartels and the mafia yeah
where do they get them from well they're
getting them legally somewhere and then
they're selling them to gangbangers
and those people selling should get in
trouble they should be held accountable
and the feds need to prosecute right
that's where the feds come in because
gang activity is largely organized crime
activity right and so you can do that's
federal prosecutions and you can
actually
prosecute murders at the federal level
very often the penalties
are greater there illinois has
incredible gun laws
to own a gun you have to have a firearm
owner id
card in the state and then you have to
have a concealed carry license to even
go out
not it's very hard to legally possess a
gun in the state so it's not
the it's they don't they talk about gun
control laws which would not solve the
problem
lori lifefoot wants to stay in her
office because she doesn't want to be
out on the street
possibly photographed in front of a body
bag but this email is
you know when we write emails that's the
most formal
method of communication i want to hear
the voicemails or where you really get
loose is in a text message it's just
going to be
a hundred poo and then peach emojis
all right lori lightfoot's texts next on
the 5.
just kidding hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else